what do you make of the
communication mechanism that we humans
use to share those ideas because
like one essential element of all of
this is not just that we're able to
have these ideas but we're also able to
share them
we tend to maybe you can correct me but
we seem to use
language to share the ideas maybe we
share them in some much deeper way than
language i don't know
but what do you make of this whole
mechanism and how fundamental it is to
the human condition so some people will
tell you that your language
dictates your thoughts and your thoughts
cannot form outside language
i tend to disagree i see
uh thoughts as much more abstract
as you know basically when i dream i
don't dream in words
i dream in shapes and forms and you know
three-dimensional space with extreme
detail
i was describing so when i wake up in
the middle of the night i actually
record my dreams sometimes i write them
down in a dropbox file
other times i'll just dictate them in
you know audio
and my wife was giving me a massage the
other day because like
my left side was frozen and i started
playing
the recording and as i was listening to
it
i was like i don't remember any of that
and i was like of course
and then the entire thing came back but
then there's no way any other person
could have
recreated that entire sort of you know
three-dimensional
uh shape and dream and concept and in
the same way when i'm thinking of ideas
there's so many ideas i can't put two
words i mean i will describe him with a
thousand words but
the idea itself is much more precise or
much more sort of abstract or much more
something you know difference either
less abstract or more abstract
and it's either you know basically
there's just the projection that happens
from the three-dimensional ideas
into let's say a one-dimensional
language um
and the language certainly gives you the
apparatus to think about concepts that
you didn't realize
existed before and with my team we often
create new words i'm like well
now we're going to call this the
regulatory plexus of a gene and that
gives us now the language to sort of
build on that as one concept that you
then build upon with all kinds of other
other things so there's this
co-evolution again of ideas and language
but they're not one-to-one uh with each
other
now let's talk about language itself
words
sentences this is a very
distant construct from where language
actually begun
so if you look at how we communicate
as i'm speaking my eyes are shining
and my face is changing through all
kinds of emotions
and my entire body composition posture
is reshaped and my intonation
the pauses that i make the softer and
the louder and this and that
are conveying so much more information
and if you look at early human language
and if you look at how you know the
great apes communicate with each other
there's a lot of granting there's a lot
of postering there's a lot of emotions
there's a lot of sort of shrieking etc
they have a lot of components of our
human language just not the words
so i think of human communication
as combining the ape
component but also of course the you
know gpt3 component
so basically there's the cognitive layer
and the reasoning layer
that we share with different parts of
our relatives
there's the ai relatives but there's
also the grunting relatives
and what i love about humanity is that
we have both
we're not just a conversational system
we're a grunting
emotionally charged you know
weirdly intercon connected
system that also has the ability to
reason
and when when we communicate with each
other
there's so much more than just language
there's so much more than just words
it does seem like we're able to somehow
transfer even more than the
the body language it seems that in the
room with us
is always a giant knowledge base
of like shared experiences different
perspectives on those experiences but i
don't know
the knowledge of who the last three four
presidents in the united states was and
just all the you know 9 11 the tragedies
in 9 11 all the
all the beautiful and uh terrible things
that happen in the world they're
somehow both in our minds and somehow
enrich the ability to transfer
information
what i love about it is i can i can talk
to you about 2001 audience of space and
mention a very specific scene and that
evokes
all these feelings that you had when you
first watched it we're both visualizing
that
maybe in different ways exactly but in
that yeah
and not only that but the feeling
uh is brought back up just like you said
with the dreams
we both have that feeling arise in some
form exactly as you bring up the
example you know uh facing his own
mortality
yeah it's fascinating that we're able to
do that but i don't know
you